you know the ellis island you would go
to the island you're an immigrant hey
what do you bring to the table i'm a
sower
i'm a person who knows how to you know
cook i'm a guy that's good with shoes
i'm a guy that's whatever right
i'm construction i'm this to say i'll
take anybody
that's that's that's like a corporation
saying i'm google i'll take anybody send
me any talent
no we're not a corporation the
government is not a corporation the
government's role is to make sure that
people are capable
the government has failed that role for
the last 40 years the government has
led people through governments the
government like for example i'll give
you an idea so you so
one problem immigration that's a problem
here that's my opinion
so oh immigration is a huge problem why
do we only get refugees why don't we get
licensed architects and licensed
professionals coming from brazil
to america why not yeah yeah
it's hard but that's not happening
listen to this look real quick and then
you're saying
i've got somebody i want to hire from
new zealand i want to hire them
i want to provide them a job they have
good skills i want
they called three attorneys all three
attorneys go too complicated won't even
take the case
we're willing to throw tens of thousands
of dollars at it won't even take the
case because the legal immigration
system is broken
why do we have a border wall issue it's
because the legal immigration system is
garbage
so go back to it so go back to the same
thing so for example you get a
how many tens of thousands of kids come
here they go to our educational system
they go through our great universities
our great schools
and then they get the four-year degree
and what do they do go back to brazil
they go back to they go back to their
country rather than keeping them yeah
but the idea
is to bring the best talent to
california or your state or your country
for you to say i'll take any hundred
sixty thousand well guess what
uh the mayor of chicago would love to
send you ten thousand people
on a greyhound bus to you for you to
handle the cost of what it takes to take
care of them
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye